Hello, so happy to be here.
Oh, my goodness,
it's so lovely to see you in this iteration,
you stunning chameleon.
(Andra laughing)
Thank you so much, and it is like a joy
and an honor to see you and meet you in person.
You're on the eve of the premiere
of this extraordinary movie.
It's so beautiful.
We're gonna look at a clip if that's all right
of The United States Vs. Billie Holiday.
What are we about to see, may I ask Andra?
So this is actually when Jimmy Fletcher,
well, he first meets Billie Holiday.
So he'd been trying to get access to her.
And so this is their first meeting
and he's really tasked by the FBI to take her down
but you start to see the beginnings
of his sort of love for her and her love for him.
So this is their first meeting.
Most of my other songs are just about love.
(gentle music)
Love is important too, right?
You know,
one day I'ma quit the drinking and get off that stuff too.
Maybe go to one of those hospitals, you know,
like Judy Garland, those movie stars.
(audience applauding)
I would love to start by asking you
what was your research process?
How did you embody this extraordinary woman?
I keep saying that word,
it's hard to find words worthy
of what you did
with bringing her to life and the life that she lived.
Thank you.
First of all, thank you.
That means everything coming from you,
but the research process, it was extensive
as I'm sort of discovering now
and researching Billie Holiday's easy for me.
I have a love for this woman
and I've loved her since I was 11 years old.
So being able to obsessively, you know,
look at material about Billie Holiday,
every book, every documentary, every photo, every interview,
every audio clip of her.
And then it was also understanding addiction, right?
That was a huge part of it,
understanding the government's role in black life
and in culture and in community and the war on drugs.
Understanding the FBI, the Federal Bureau of Narcotics,
and then Lee, working with Lee, talking with Lee every day
and just about who he wanted his Billie to be.
And just the different layers of sort of her humanity.
And then I worked closely with Tasha Smith,
who was my acting coach and with Tom Jones
who was my dialect coach to help me really, you know,
fine-tune her voice and to inform all of my research
with an actual human being, as you know.
(Andra laughing)
And then I sat with multiple heroin addicts
and recovering addicts
and just to understand really the underlying trauma
and the mental illness of addiction.
That was a huge, huge part of it.
And then bodily, the transformation,
lost almost 40 pounds, I don't smoke or drink,
but I started smoking cigarettes
and drinking a lot of gin.
(Andra laughing)
And just generally changing my behavior,
being more sexual, I'm actually abstinent,
and being just more loose with my words and my language,
and just trying to live as her for two years,
three years of my life.
It's evident.
Thank you.
And it really pays off.
And when you speak of Lee, it's Lee Daniels the director,
who was also nominated for an Academy Award
for his extraordinary film,
there it is the word again, Precious.
The way that this film is handled
and I believe the timing of it.
It goes from being what could have been a biopic
into what I believe is the most perfect portrayal
of a history lesson.
And I've been a long-time fan.
I've spent my whole life listening to Billie Holiday.
In fact, I was playing her
when my daughter Frankie was born.
She was born to, God Bless the Child,
it's a very auspicious moment.
I have a question, now that you have lived and embodied
and you provide us with the knowledge
and the message of who Billie Holiday was.
Can I ask you, how should I listen to her now?
Wow, first of all,
that is an incredible question, a huge question.
And I've never ever been asked that before.
And so thank you first of all, for asking that.
That just means a lot.
I really want people to just love and to appreciate her
and understand her as a fighter.
You know, she didn't want people just to enjoy her music.
She wanted people to, she was integrating audiences,
she was a civil rights leader.
And so I want people when they listen to her music
I want them to think of her in the conversations
of Martin Luther King, of Malcolm X, of Medgar Evers,
of James Baldwin, of Assata Shakur, of Angela Davis.
So I want that through line into Black Lives Matter now
to Patrisse Cullors, to Stacey Abrams, to VP Kamala Harris,
Michelle, she's in that strain, in that DNA,
she paved the way.
So thank you for asking that.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
So much
for this in our lives right now.
(upbeat music)